[Music]
we have two brand new agents in this
film who are allies to james bond the
world's moved on commander bond you were
double o two yes nomi is highly skilled
slightly cocky you get in my way i will
put a bullet in your knee
the one that works
there's a young lady in santiago i want
you to meet paloma you're late
ma is a cuban agent she's intense
i had many action scenes thank god i had
an amazing stunt team
they put me through a true military
training i really wanted to get it right
and looked like i knew what i was doing
no time to die represents change we see
so many different examples of women
being strong in this movie
and being badasses at that
nope
two
bond any thug can kill
i have to know i can trust you
[Music]
well i understand double those have a
very short life expectancy
you are a kite dancing in a hurricane mr
bond
is this really what you want
always alone
[Music]
we used to be able to get into a room
with the enemy
and now they're just floating in the
ether
when our secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of you
oh my god target enough people
remember people become the weapon
who is he james
you don't know what this is
james want
license to kill
in love with madeleine swann
i could be speaking to my own reflection
only your skills die with your body
and life is all about leaving something
behind
isn't it
come on bond where the hell are you
[Music]
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
i have to finish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you